animal crossing New Horizons is finally
out and if you want your island to
succeed there are a few things you have
to do on day one so let's get started
after you've completed the tutorial you
should be able to craft a net end
fishing rod once you've made these you
should catch as many bugs and fish as
you can and donate five of them to Tom
Nook after you've done that nook we'll
call up his old friend blathers and ask
you to pick a spot for blathers tent
which he'll set up the next day blathers
gives you access to the shovel and
vaulting pole so it's best to get this
done ASAP unfortunately you won't be
able to donate anything for the rest of
the day so I recommend throwing down any
new species you catch on the ground
until you can donate more tomorrow if
you haven't already make sure to track
down both your villagers and chat with
them doing so should net you some new
items and nook miles next make sure to
comb the beach for shells to sell and
more importantly for a message in a
bottle there should be a new bottle
almost every day and each one contains a
DIY recipe considering it's your first
day you should get a new recipe just
don't forget to select it from your
inventory and read it if you're still
light on bells in furniture I highly
recommend shaking every tree you can on
your island
obviously there are parts of the island
you still can't access yet but there
should be plenty of trees in your
vicinity
now obviously most trees will drop
branches but occasionally some will drop
bells or furniture I should also mention
here that wasps nests can also fall out
of trees
I recommend equipping your net so you
can catch a wasp in case that happens
they are worth twenty-five hundred bells
after all now this one's a bit strange
but if you're familiar with Animal
Crossing you'll know exactly what I'm
talking about you should hit every
single rock on your island hitting rocks
will net you resources like clay stone
iron nuggets and if you're lucky gold
nuggets iron is especially important
when it comes to crafting so we
recommend getting as much of it as you
can
however crafting materials aren't the
only thing that can come out of rocks
once per day there is one rock that will
spew money every time you hit it
normally I'd recommend using your shovel
for this because you can dig a couple
holes to brace yourself but since you
can't get a shovel until day two the
flimsy axe will have to do you can place
two pieces of furniture behind you
instead so you don't recoil so much next
up you should pull all your weeds this
may seem a bit tedious but pulling weeds
has a few advantages first you can sell
your weeds to Timmy
second pulling and selling weeds can get
you some new clothes and third there are
some DIY recipes that require weeds so
it's good to have a few on hand just in
case finally it's time to pay off your
debt to Tom Nook this loan will run you
almost fifty thousand bells or five
thousand Nick my lament paying this off
with Nook miles five thousand may seem
like a lot but you should rack up plenty
of miles from exploring your Island
one of the best perks of owning a house
and new horizons is that you'll have
access to a storage inventory home
ownership also unlocks Nook miles Plus
which provides you with a rotating
selection of nook miles bonuses to chase
so it's good to get started on it early
and that's it for me if there's
something I missed please leave it in
the comments below and be sure to check
out our review in progress
[Music]